la découverte de notre à dernis ficr de
la soirée audio - le dernier speaker
officiel
il se nomme magie la taille il a débuté
son parcours professionnel en côte
d'ivoire en 1985 en occupant des postes
à de hautes responsabilités dans les
domaines du marketing du management et
de la planification stratégique en
afrique et en europe depuis septembre à
2007 il a décidé de mettre son expertise
et son expérience au service des
personnes et des institutions en afrique
dans les développe dans les domaines
plutôt de la stratégie de développement
et du leadership en créant sa propre
compagnie basée à johannesburg
souvenez vous lors du tedx précédent il
devait être un des nôtres mais il n'a
pas pu être là il nous a envoyé une
vidéo fono montry son soutien pour nous
dit qu'ils seraient là avec nous lors du
prochain dead et bien c'est chose faite
il est avec nos hôtes pour cette
troisième édition du tedx à vian salon
merci cher public de recevoir monsieur
sylla taillis
et
bonsoir vous allez bien faire c'est
intéressant d'être le dernier à parler
parce que tous mes collègues avant ont
juste bien chauffer la salle
et moi je vais profiter de tout ceci si
vous le voulez bien moi je veux changer
le monde pas moins que ça je veux
changer le monde et je pense que je peux
changer le monde mais pour cela j'ai
deux convictions que je partage avec
vous en commençant cette conversation
la première conviction c'est que je ne
pense pas d'ailleurs je suis même sûr
que le monde dans lequel nous vivons
n'est pas condamnée à vivre dans la
minorité dans le mal dans la violence
dans le mensonge
dans toutes ces choses dont nous avons
honte même de parler en public de tout
ce mal qui est savamment est habilement
entretenue par une petite minorité mais
le monde peut vivre la promesse qui lui
était faite d'être un monde où malgré la
compétition entre les nations malgré la
compétition entre les organisations
malgré la compétition entre les
personnes ce monde peut être un monde de
coopération un mot de portage un mou de
bonheur où chacun peut se retrouver sans
faire du mal à l'autre cette image qui
est derrière moi résume tout à fait ce à
quoi je rêve
voyez-vous derrière moi il y à la
résolution du problème de l'éducation il
ya la résolution du problème de la santé
pour la communauté
il ya la résolution du problème de
l'égalité des genres il y à même la
résolution de nos problèmes d'énergie
d'infrastructures
ces enfants dont je vois le sourire ici
derrière moi représente le chief min
la destination de ce que je pense le
maître le monde peut être ça c'est ma
première condition
mais pour que ce monde arrive et c'est
là maintenant ma seconde conviction il
faudrait que nous devenions réellement
consciemment chacun d'entre nous non
seulement nos propre gardien mais aussi
les gardiens de nos frères
cette expression gardien de son frère la
première fois que moi je la vois en tout
cas c'est quand je commence à lire des
livres très sérieux et que je lis
l'histoire de caïn et abel k1 sassine
abel et puis se promenant il fait la
rencontre du seigneur de dieu et dieu
lui demande où est ton frère etc est la
réponse de kaya serais-je le gardien de
mon frère à l'évidence ne l'était pas
parce que s'il avait été non seulement
ils n'auraient pas assassiné mais il
aurait même aidé à parfaire les
offrandes kabel faisait pour dieu
mais aujourd'hui les sauts même ça de
côté
c'est quoi être gardien de son frère
alors au premier niveau
c'est peut-être soutenir l'autre c'est
veiller sur l'autre c'est lui donner à
manger à boire quand il en a besoin
c'est également le vêtir lorsqu'il en a
besoin c'est lui apporter ce dont il a
besoin le visiter quand il est malade le
soutenir le faire beaucoup de choses
pour lui en gros on pourrait dire
apporter un soutien matériel moral et
même spirituelles mais ce qu'on va voir
ensemble
chers amis c'est que ça va un peu plus
loin que ceux ci et c'est même un peu
plus subtil quoique moins difficile et
pour cela je leur racontais petite
anecdote qui m'est arrivé il y a
quelques années à johannesbourg où
j'habite
ce jour là j'ai voulu faire plaisir à
mon épouse comme j'essaie de le faire
tous les jours
et j'ai voulu faire pour elle de course
du mois
donc nous voilà au supermarché et je
sens une super machine le caddie donc je
sors du casier justement c'est que le
caddie et là je vois au niveau du
parking
un monsieur occupé à ramasser des
feuilles usées des papiers lisez et à
les mettre dans une poubelle
ce monsieur à l'évidence quand tu le
regardes tu vois qu'il n'est pas préposé
à 7 h c'est un monsieur comme vous et
moi c'était m'occuper qui a beaucoup de
responsabilités professionnelles mais
qui comprend certainement qu'il est
important que l'environnement soit
propre
alors le voici ce death en ramassant une
feuille ramasser une autre
la méthode en thelle poubelles regardant
ce scan ans et puis faisant son travail
je ne dois pas être un modèle de
discrétion parce que il remarque la
présence
il se retourne et vient vers moi ils me
demandent dans un anglais parfait
vous vous demandez ce que je fais n'est
ce pas et avant que je lui réponde
il me dit je m'occupe de mettre les
papiers usées dans les poubelles parce
que les papiers usées ont comme
destination la poubelle avant que je ne
réalise ce qui m'arrive
il disparaît je vais être honnête avec
vous
jusqu'aujourd'hui je ne sais pas si je
vis un ange ou si je vis un homme parce
que l'impression que ce monsieur a
laissé sur moi est extraordinaire il m'a
marqué d'une manière incroyable
il m'a donné une inspiration tel
qu'aujourd'hui je ne supporte plus de
voir un pas qui traînait j'y vais je les
ramasse et je cherche la première
poubelle pour lui m
ce monsieur a été pour moi ce que
j'appelle un gardien de son frère voyez
vous il ne m'a pas donné de l'argent il
ne m'a même pas visiter il ne m'a pas
dit il ne m'a pas donné à manger ou à
boire mais il m'a inspiré il m'a donné
plus que cela il a eu sur moi un impact
à cause d'une interruption de quelques
secondes qui fait que jusqu'aujourd'hui
je me souviens je n'oublierai jamais ce
monsieur nous sommes tous mesdames
messieurs le produit de nos expériences
bonnes ou moins bonnes mon nom est
gilles à tailler le tout-petit bien
qu'ils vite en moi je le dois d'abord à
dieu mais je dois après à ma mère à mon
père à mon épouse à nos enfants à mes
amis ce que j'aime qui m'aiment et ceux
qui éventuellement ne même pas ça arrive
ça arrive mais ils ont tous participé à
faire de moi la personne qui se tient
devant vous aujourd'hui
mais il n'ya pas qu'eux il y à toutes
les personnes qui ont croisé mon chemin
un jour que ce soit juste un regard une
tape dans le dos un sourire une
conversation
ils ont tous pu tous ces gens l impact
dans ma vie et qu'y fait la personne que
je suis chacun de vous d'ailleurs dans
cette salle a rencontré des personnes et
certains d'entre vous ont été marqués
par une rencontre qui fut juste le temps
d'une conversation d'un sourire ou des
regards mais qui vous a transformé et
qui a fait la personne que vous êtes
devenu aujourd'hui tout à l'heure je
parlais de cette personne que j'ai
rencontrée quelques secondes et j'ai dit
il est
pour moi un gardien il était pour moi et
gardien de son frère que je suis mais
c'est quoi un gardien de son frère
l'interview de son frère c'est tout
simplement une personne qui vous
aspirent
non sans nécessairement vous donner
matériellement moralement
spirituellement sans avoir à sortir de
l'argent de sa poche sans avoir à
investir du temps pour vous rencontrer
mais c'est juste une personne qui fait
quelque chose qui vous inspirent qui
nous élève
c'est une personne qui vous amène à
avoir envie de faire plus de recherche
est pas la discipline l'excellence une
personne qui vous donne un impact elle
que vous ne pouvez plus être la même
personne
après l'avoir rencontré et moi je veux
changer le monde
je veux arriver à impacter la vie de
toutes les personnes autour de moi que
ce soit dans ma famille on épouse mariam
à nos enfants mes amis mes ennemis
toutes les personnes que je rencontre je
veux avoir un impact sûrs et lui donc je
veux changer le monde et je suis en
marche pour le faire mais ce que j'ai
compris c'est que je veux d'abord
commencer par l'afrique
d'ailleurs j'ai déjà commencé et
pourquoi je veux commencer par l'afrique
parce que c'est de là que je viens et
c'est là où je vais parce que ce
continent a beaucoup les cas lundi on va
les voir tout à l'heure mais aussi parce
que le plus de ressources de talent que
nous avons doit être mobilisé vers une
pause sérieuse 11,7 suffisamment amusé
et j'expliquais tout à l'heure pourquoi
il faut que nous changions nos
paradigmes
moi je veux changer également l'afrique
parce que je suis juste fatigué de
m'excuser d'être africain il y en a
marre d'être toujours en train de dire
l'africain là-bas et puis d'expliquer
pourquoi tu africains mais je sais par
contre les grands challenges que nous
avons il nous faut absolument gagner la
bataille de l'éducation et 8 en a parlé
tout à l'heure
tout le monde en a parlé labat l
éducation ont de la gagner nous devons
gagner la bataille de la santé pour nos
communautés urbaines et rurales
nous devons gagner la bataille de
l'énergie et de l'infrastructure
nous devons gagner la bataille de la
sécurité alimentaire
il faut que tout le monde puisse manger
et manger bien équilibré normalement oui
je crois qu'on peut y arriver en afrique
il faut que nous gagnons la bataille de
l'intégrité des personnes et des biens
l'égalité des genres c'est stupide de
penser que parce qu'on est né différent
avec un sexe différent on n'a pas accès
aux mêmes choses mais ce monde va
changer parce que vous savez quoi
il n'y a plus que les fils n'y a pas que
les fans qui se battent pour ça des
hommes ont rejoint le combat il faut que
ça change
et enfin il faut que nous gagnons la
bataille de la responsabilité et de la
bonne influence
vous voyez la première image la grande
ce sont des grandes conférences alors on
dit monsieur france que penses-tu on les
écoute
monsieur grande bretagne que penses-tu
on l'écouté madame états unis on
l'écouté et puis quand on en vient la
côte d'ivoire au sénégal au togo bénin
on dit merci d'être présent
j'ai dans la salle ici en face de moi et
je rends grâce à dieu pour ça
suffisamment de personnes qui ont
beaucoup d'autorité on doit pas rire
avec ça c'est sérieux regardez vous ird
influence est hyper de s vous l
influence vous avez tellement de gens
que vous pouvez impacté réaliser combien
votre rôle est important
combien tout ce que vous dites ne dit
pas fait et ne fait pas à un impact sur
des millions de personnes madame la vice
président de lettres quelqu'un de très
important je le reconnais votre fille
nature peut changer beaucoup de choses
et vous le savez de manière consciente
il faudrait faire yvon simon attention à
ce que vous dites ne dit pas fait ne
fait pas parce que soit vous élever
soit vous écraser moi je veux changer le
monde et j'ai commencé je vous dirai ce
que j'ai fait parce que quand tu veux
attaquer une bataille aussi grande que
celle que je viens de décrire
tu ne peux pas aller gaiement la fleur
au fusil
tu te prépares tu t' équipe tu te motive
tu mange bien et qui va oui il faut bien
manger tu mange bien et puis tu vas ce
qu'on l'a fait ah oui j'ai pas dit
pendant 22 ans quand j'ai commencé ma
carrière en 85
j'ai d'abord travaillé dans le monde
comme pour être prêt pour des grandes
multinationales moi bien utilisé bien
utilisé d'ailleurs j'étais très content
d'avoir vu tout à l'heure une image
d'une campagne quand je suis dans une
ces compagnies là bas j'ai vu une image
d'une campagne j'étais directeur
marketing pour ce grand groupe
multinational et je suis content d'avoir
dû didier tout à l'heure une image d'une
des campagnes donc j'ai bien travaillé
et puis en septembre 2007 il ya huit ans
j'ai décidé que je voulais arrêter je
suis aller m'installer en afrique du sud
où j'ai commencé ma propre activité n'a
su moment là je voulais savoir qu'est ce
qu'il y avait en nous africains que nous
voyons en quelqu'un qui nous motive
qui nous mobilise qui nous redynamise
qui nous donne envie de faire plus alors
dans ces 20 pays
nous avons été et nous avons interrogé
des personnes qui décident et elles nous
ont donné les critères qui font
l'africain qui est non seulement le
leader mais que le gardien de ses frères
et je voulais juste vous montrez faut
être technique de trois choses qu'on a
vues
je voulais savoir dans le regard des
africains eux mêmes quels étaient les
toffes du leader ou plutôt du gardien de
ses frères et rapidement on a vu que
nous les africains nous aimons les
personnes qui voit loin et avant les
autres
nous aimons les gens qui ont du courage
du caractère qui hors de l'intégrité qui
compte une capacité technique qui honte
l esprit l'équipe et qui savent
communiquer regarder derrière moi dans
ces six compétences y en a une seule qui
soit technique
le reste ne l'est pas la seule qui est
technique c'est la capacité technique à
jongler donc la communication ce qu'on a
compris c'est que pour changer ce monde
ce n'est pas de plus de technique et de
sciences dont nous avons besoin crois
que nous avons besoin mêlant
d'intelligence émotionnelle et je vous
dire ce que l'intelligence émotionnelle
elles apportent elles apportent la
détermination
elle apporte l'engagement elle apporte
le courage le goût de l'effort la
résilience la discipline l'empathie le
caractère la volonté de se dépasser
le sens du devoir le dos de soi le désir
de partager la recherche de l'équité et
de la justice
le désir de solutions constructives et
enfin les solutions gagnantes à nantes
ce que je veux dire ni amen
ce que je veux dire pensez-y deux
secondes et aucune insulte aux
professions que je vais citer combien de
médecins connaissons nous aujourd'hui
qu'ils ont oublié le serment
d'hippocrate et qui font des choses qui
n'ont rien à voir avec ce pour quoi ils
sont d'abord allés à l'université de
médecine
combien d'avocats véreux
connaissons-nous mais qu'ils ont tous la
capacité technique à ils connaissent la
loi
ils connaissent le corps humain combien
d'ingénieurs n'ont rien fait de leur vie
que juste travailler pour eux et pour
leurs ventes
ce que je veux dire c'est que ce n'est
pas de plus de sciences et de techniques
dont ce continent a besoin c'est de plus
d'engagement moral s'est de plus
intelligence émotionnelle et moi et moi
je me suis déjà mise en route
quand j'ai commencé on a dit il rêve
mais vous savez quoi
j'ai converti pas mal de gens et les
gens qu'on a converti sont en train de
convertir
nous sommes en train de travailler à la
réalisation d'une masse critique de
personnes conscientes qui veulent de
manière disciplinée
arrivé à l'excellence dans ce continent
a besoin nous sommes déjà en route
oui je veux changer le monde
est ce que j'ai en visière c'est la
création d'une masse critique de
gardiens de leur frère
conscients de leur mission pour une
cause plus grande que leur petite
personne prochaine floyd je suis tout
petit parce que la cause est plus grande
que chacun donc nous pris
individuellement
la grande chance de pouvoir parler à des
grands patrons d'entreprises faire ce
qu'on appelle des sciences de
transformation où soudainement les
personnes comprennent que dans leur rôle
ce n'est pas juste de faire plaisir à
l'employeur mais c'est de m
personne au coeur de leur stratégie de
croissance nous travaillons avec des
personnes pour les amener à être
meilleur j'aime beaucoup la triptyque de
mon ami qui vient du mandat il a parlé
de leurs vues meliti on a parlé donc de
trois grandes valeurs et c'est ça qui te
fait avancer le monde d'aujourd'hui a
besoin d'un discours nouveau sinon on
aura les mêmes bêtises qui nous
entourent toujours et ce monde il est
possible qu'ils arrivent
moi je veux changer le monde et quand je
suis fatiguée parce que ça m'arrive
quand le matin je n'ai plus envie de me
réveiller quand tu essayais lee défaite
cuisante
quand j'ai pris une baffe
quand j'ai été refoulés quand j'ai été
humilié quand j'ai été insulté quand on
m'a fermé la porte
quand on a ri de moi je me lève quand
même pourquoi pas ce que j'ai en images
ce que j'ai derrière ça ça mal mais ça
ça m'aide à me lever
ça ça m'aide à essieu le crash a commis
au visage ça me permet d'avancer un
kilomètre encore et le deuxième
kilomètre je le ferai demain le
troisième après demain je ne lâche pas
et pas seulement moi mais toutes les
personnes qui comprennent que ce monde
peut changer
sitôt que nous changeons notre manière
de penser et de regarder l'un à l'autre
alors oui moi j'ai commencé mon chemin
mais ce que j'ai compris et qui a
déshabillé un peu ma personne de tous et
égaux qui existent en moi c'est de
comprendre que seul c'était impossible
alors j'ai commencé alliance faire et
durable avec les gens qui sont autour de
moi dans ma famille dans les communautés
auxquelles j'appartiens dans mepi parce
que j'ai plusieurs pays en même temps
dans tous les endroits où je vais et je
suis heureux de voir que je suis devenu
un vecteur de contamination une maladie
pandémique
oui j'avais déjà fait j'ai fait encore
et toutes les personnes que j'ai fait un
fait et on a fait à provisions jusqu'à
ce que nous ayons la masse critique qui
puisse changer ce monde
la chose dont je me souviens et qui me
garde éveillé c'est ce qu'elle fit je
sais que tout ce que je dis tout ce que
je ne dis pas tout ce que je fais tout
ce que je ne fais pas tout compte et
tout ceci à la capacité soin d'élever
soit d'écraser j'ai choisi de lever
alors je fais attention à ce que je dis
je fais attention à ce que je ne dis pas
je fais attention à ce que je fais je
fais attention à ce que je ne fais pas
mes paroles mais silence mes actions
mais abstinence doivent travailler
uniquement pour ceux qui aujourd'hui
fait ma passion je disais tout à l'heure
je suis peut-être fatigué mais je
retrouve toujours l'énergie quand je
travaille parce que qu'est ce que vous
voulez je travaille qui est tellement
bien on transforme de vie on parle d'un
grand projet les gens nous suivent
ça arrive et je suis payé
on me paye et des fois bien souvent même
bien sinon je fais pas non mesdames
messieurs ce continent peut réussir
on est toujours en train de dire que
nous sommes en marche vers quelque chose
qu'on ne voit jamais mais la première
chose qu'on doit faire vraiment c'est
que nous devenons tous les gardiens de
nos frères pas simplement un support
matériel
ce n'est pas de l'argent seulement c'est
juste de faire attention à ce que nous
faisons devenir une source d'inspiration
pour chacune des personnes qui est à
côté de nous afin que même juste à votre
nom des gens est envie de faire ce qui
est bien
alors je vais m'engager ici devant vous
en levant la main gauche parce que la
menant en levant la main droite
je m'engage à être le gardien de tous
les frères que j'avoue que j'ai dans
cette salle si je rencontre qui que ce
soit dans cette salle et que ce n'est
même qu'un sourire je donnerais afin que
tu sois inspiré mais j'ai besoin de
savoir si toi en lunettes là est ce que
tu peux te garder quelqu'un lève la main
si tu peux alors tu te lèves même c'est
même mieux derrière toi tu peux ok
est-ce que j'ai deux gardiens dans la
salle je vous vois pas mettez vous
debout
oh oh c'est beau paul et moi ça en photo
c'est magnifique c'est magnifique c'est
magnifique
c'est magnifique
nous avons 1500 gardien de leur format
seixal dieu vous bénisse merci beaucoup